air transat devoir rapatrier les 113
passagers mais on suit aussi pour ce qui
est des autres sorties premier ministre
du québec françois legault l'annoncé
hier en fin de journée
la centaine de touristes canadiens
coincés dans un hôtel en haïti seront
évacués ce matin à partir de 9h je vous
rappelle par groupe de dix sept
personnes
héliporté jusqu'à l'aéroport de port au
prince pour ensuite prendre un vol
direction montréal la ministre du
développement international marie claude
bibeau est avec nous en direct de
sherbrooke madame bibeau bonjour bonjour
est ce que vous avez d'autres détails
savez vous a quelle heure les gens
seront rapatriés ici à montréal alors
les au travail
c'est vraiment le gouvernement du canada
avec notre ambassadeur du canada en
haïti les autorités locales
et évidemment air transat le voyagiste
qui collaborent pour mettre en place
tout le plan d'évacuation donc notre but
c'est vraiment de s'assurer qu'ils vont
être rapatriés dans les meilleurs délais
dans de façon très sécuritaire parce
qu'on sait que c'est vraiment la voie
terrestre entre l'hôtel et l'aréopage
qui pose un problème depuis plusieurs
jours alors on est en train de mettre en
place un plan d'évacuation donc on
s'attend à ce qu'il rentre au pays
autour du début de la soirée environ
on collabore tout le monde ensemble pour
pour que ça se fasse dans les meilleurs
délais donc c'est pas qu'il arrive fier
à ce moment ci c'est ce que je comprends
vous dites que c'est le gouvernement du
canada qui opère tout ça la nouvelle est
arrivée par le premier ministre du
québec françois legault assez
surprenante ont même que la nouvelle
viennent du québec et non pas d'ottawa
alors quand on travaille sur des plans
d'évacuation des canadiens dans un pays
en conflit
on informe les autres chefs d'état ou le
preuve premiers ministres de provinces
par exemple ils sont plus
particulièrement concernés par
courtoisie je dirais mais vraiment il
faut être très très prudent quand on
partage des informations pour un plan
d'évacuation de canadiens dans un pays
en conflit parce que ça pourrait
compromettre leur sécurité de donner
trop de détails sur ce plan alors c'est
pour ça qu'au niveau du gouvernement du
canada on se fait plus discret canton il
s'agit de donner les détails d'un plan
d'évacuation
je comprends donc vous aviez décidé de
garder l'information par mesure de
sécurité pour les ressortissants là bas
oui alors moi j'étais en contact avec la
fille du couple de sherbrookois qui sont
là bas donc on a une relation avec les
familles qui se sont identifiés auprès
des affaires mondiales canada et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour encourager
tous les canadiens qui voyagent prenez
la peine d'aller sur le site internet du
gouvernement pour voir s'il ya des avis
de voyage ou de recommandation de ne pas
voyager et inscrivez vous pour qu'on
sache où vous êtes pendant quelle
période à l'extérieur du pays
concernant l'opération d'évacuation
quelle est l'évaluation des risques que
vous faites pour les prochaines heures
aujourd'hui les risques c'est vraiment
terrestre donc parce que ce sont des
manifestations bon des citoyens haïtiens
qui manifestent par rapport à leur
insatisfaction face aux aux présidentes
au gouvernement alors c'est sûr qu'en
utilisant une voie alternative parlée
par les airs c'est certainement une voix
très très sécuritaire pour les canadiens
qui qui vont revenir au pays à très
bientôt donc est-ce que vous avez un peu
d'informations concernant les jeunes qui
font un voyage humanitaire je pense aux
élèves des écoles le boisé le tandem de
victoriaville une trentaine d'élèves
d'accompagnateur est-ce que vous avez la
garantie qu'ils reviendront en fin de
semaine
eux aussi ils se trouvent dans une
situation qui est tout à fait dans une
situation dans une région qui est tout à
fait calme en ce moment donc il n'y a
pas à s'inquiéter pour eux évidemment
que on collabore avec les organisateurs
les responsables de ce groupe pour
s'assurer que lorsqu'ils vont se
déplacer ça va se faire de façon
sécuritaire
d'accord je me donne que vous avez une
pensée très très précise et moi quel
genre de pensées vous avez mais pour les
haïtiens parce que vous êtes allé quand
même à quelques reprises en voyage en
haïti
oui sauf que c'est difficile je suis
allé déjà trois fois j'ai rencontré le
président quelques reprises le premier
ministre aussi c'est difficile de voir
de voir la situation actuelle autant de
violence parce que c'est certainement
pas par la violence qu'on va trouver une
solution
le pays fait face à des défis
énorme au point de vue économique
évidemment mais au point de vue de toute
son organisation de sa gouvernance le
canada c'est pour nous pour combiner
développement international je peux vous
dire que c'est un des pays les plus
importants là où on a le plus gros
programme des dotant des aides
humanitaires que d'être beaucoup dans le
secteur de la santé on a énormément
d'organisations canadiennes qui sont la
bonne au secteur de la santé ont fait de
l'assistance technique aussi aux
services policiers donc d'ailleurs on a
plusieurs policiers canadiens qui sont
sur le terrain qui font de la formation
des officiers haïtien est évidemment
différent programme d'appui à la
gouvernance
l'ambassade du canada et y est toujours
fermée aujourd'hui j'imagine l'ambassade
et physiquement fermée mais notre
ambassadeur et quelques membres du
personnel seniors sont en haïti et toute
l'équipe au niveau consulaires donc ceux
qui doivent apporter de l'aide aux
canadiens qui pourraient avoir besoin de
nous sont en fonction de l'étranger
alors peut-être rappeler aux gens que
s'ils ont besoin de communiquer avec
nous la façon la plus facile c'est
probablement sos un commercial
international.gc.ca c'est noté mary
claude bibeau ministre du développement
international et merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci bien
merci à vous revoir